Har du några tips till alla därute som har ett företag?
Hur stärker man sitt varumärke?
Hur får man den här i lek?
Om man inte kan sponsra OS.
Hehehehe Hur gör man i modern tid för att bygga sitt varumärke?
Jag ringde mina kollegor, vi ska starta en podd nu.
Löste, vi börjar spela in på måndag.
Jag ska ringa Alton Bladet sen.
Jag ska hitta på ett namn på podden.
Är det den bästa idé vi har?
Men det är inte den sämsta idé vi har.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Exakt, exakt.
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt.
Det kör vi på.
Det får det bli.
Klart.
Då går vi vidare.
Då välkomnar vi Oskar Ragvald som är Commercial Director på Eleiko till podden.
Så mycket.
Kul att vara här.
Ja, det känns för jävla bra.
Vi kan väl inleda med att vi gjorde en supermiss här.
Jag sitter på huvudkontoret i Halmstad och du sitter hemma.
Jag sitter hemma.
Det är det digitala århundrandet.
Om man inte talar om en plats så tänkte man digitalt, men är det lite udda?
Jag hälsar på här, stör dina kolleger, försökte fixa hörlurar, ett mötesrum och...
Det är lite udda, men vi gör det bästa av er.
Det gör vi.
Jag tänker att vi gör en liten kort intro om dig, så att folk vet vem du är.
Skulle vi kunna få en sådan his pitch?
His pitch?
Nej men i grund och botten, jag är någonstans från idrottssidan, har gått i idrottshymnasie, tänkte bli portionell fotbollsspelare, men ett dåligt beslut på en högerhörna ledde mig till rehab-träning på Nautilus Gymmilund, som egentligen blev en 20-årig resa som tog mig runt och öppnade gymmen runtom i norra Europa, tillsammans med en gäng entreprenörer, två riskkapitalbolag och sen till sist en börsintroduktion med Actic 2017 och då var jag CEO för Actic vid den tiden.
Och sen så kan man väl säga att då hade jag väl...
Helvete nu går du nästan för fort här.
Du var CEO där under den...
Så du var med redan från start i den resan?
Nej, jag kom in...
Man kan ju inte komma in här, jag kom nu in halvvakt.
För då var det tre entreprenörer som drev en outlö som hade tre väldigt begåvade entreprenörer som hade ett ganska intressant och smart koncept.
Och jag kom in ett par år innan de...
Jag kom nu in tio år innan de gjorde den första exiten där FSN Capital köpte företaget.
Och då började jag, haltade jag in där på ett gym i Lund där de började reaktränna och sen så slutade det med att jag sen blev regionchef i samband med att man blev köpt av FSN Capital.
Och man skulle börja bygga organisation som ofta är i den fasen när ett PE-bolag kommer in då så ska man professionalisera bolaget.
Och jag passade väl kanske i mallen.
Jag hade en universitetsutbildning, jag kunde branscha något sådant här.
Och sen så rullade det där på.
Så jag var ju Sverigeschef för bolaget fram till nästa exit när IKO Industrikapital köpte det.
Och sen efter det så ville man ju då bli internationella.
Och då var jag ju operativchef för företaget i Tantalore.
Och sen så blev det etablering.
Så jag etablerade och köpte en mäller massa klubbar runtom i Sverige, Tyskland och Norge.
Jag tror vi rullade 50 klubbar om året ett tag.
Och sen så till sist tillbaka till Snabbstullningspunkten i 2017 när vi börsintroducerade Aktik.
Och då någonstans kan man väl säga att då kände jag att jag har nu gjort vad jag ska här.
Så det var mer en fråga.
I den typen av sammanhang så har man inte alltid full valfrihet om vad man gör den närmsta tiden av livet.
Så i 2019 så kläv jag ut ganska exakt två år efter börsintroduktionen.
Visste väl egentligen inte vad jag ville.
Men jag tyckte att...
Först hade jag kanske tänkt att jag skulle ta det ganska lugnt.
Och se vad livet...
Som många tänker men det blir aldrig så.
Ja men jag tänkte mig att det här är allt det här.
Jag hade massa böcker, jag hade inte fått läsa och visste att jag tränade alltid, men jag ville träna med och så vidare.
Så det gick liksom en månad där och så kände jag att...
Och då lyckades jag, jag lyckades till och med pressa min så att jag kom tillbaka och sprang 38 minuter på bilen.
Och då efter ett tag började jag känna att det här var inte alls vad jag hade tänkt mig.
Även innan dess hade jag haft en dialog med Erik Blomberg, men då började jag trakassera honom, kan man väl säga om man inte hade någonting att göra.
För det var i Lepo som jag kände att om jag skulle börja jobba i ett företag igen så är det Lepo.
Och då under sommaren där.
Varför?
Väldigt mycket för dels för att jag genuint kände att man hade starka värderingar som man levde, också när man levde i den världen som jag kanske var i då med riskkapitalbolag.
Där som i början var väldigt bra måste jag säga, de var duktiga för sin kapital men man kom in och det blev börsrapportering och så vidare.
Jag tyckte jag kom längre och längre ifrån anledningen till att egentligen började jobba i den branschen.
Så kände jag att familj kändes väldigt attraktivt och jag kände också att man låg nära sina värderingar.
Och så ska jag verkligen säga att varumärket, så som man har byggt upp det och att man hade investerat i det var någonting som vi inte verkligen gjorde eller fick lov att göra med Aktic.
Var det ju att investera i varumärket och det är något som Eleco verkligen hade gjort, var det ju byggt ett väldigt starkt varumärke.
Så de delarna gjorde att jag kände att det här attraherar mig väldigt mycket.
Och det var också så att den sidan av Bramkorn fick jag jobba i.
Kan man väl säga att gå ut och driva gym hade tatt några år innan jag hade fått lov att göra.
Så egentligen var de delarna som jag kände var väldigt attraktivt med Eleco.
Men kände du folket på Eleco eller var det bara på hörsägen som du ville in?
Nej, jag kände folket på Eleco för vi hade ju varit en rätt så stor kund till Eleco.
Och sen så lite så också att en del andra personer som jag hade jobbat med på Actic hade också hamnat upp på Eleco genom åren här.
Så jag kände en hel del människor in i det och kände att det här var genuint.
För det är väl det som är, många bolag har ju, som du säkert ser, jättebra värderingar om man läser dem på papper.
Men om man skapar lite på det så känns det fast, ja, är det verkligen så här.
Och jag kände att Eleco, där vill man faktiskt sätta på riktigt.
Och det var attraktivt och riktigt kul och inspirerande att göra det.
Men jag hade som sagt från början, kanske hade tänkt mig någonting annat.
Jag började fundera, jag tror jag handgöra ett konsultjobb också någonstans där i de månaderna mitt ifrån kommunen också.
Men jag ångrar inte mig i alla fall, så kan vi se.
Men så du började på Eleco någonstans 2017 slutet eller 2018?
Nej 2019.
Så börsinton där så var jag kvar i två år.
Okej, jag använder mig på kedjan.
Så man kan säga att en väldigt enkelspårig karriär, väldigt smal, har gjort i stort sett alla positioner på Actic då.
Jag var faktiskt tillförordnad vd under några perioder också.
Så jag har gjort alla positioner utom CFO brukar jag säga, allt från att vara tränare på golvet till att bygga utbildningsprogram till nu i Eleiko.
Så ett väldigt smal, väldigt mycket idrott, men samtidigt väldigt passionerad för träningen av den här branschen.
Vad är det du gör nu på Eleiko?
En bra fråga.
Vi pratade om din titel här innan och bara det tog en kvart att få fram.
Det tog en kvart att få fram titeln att komma på vilken den var nu.
När vi går under botten så är vi organiserade med dotterbolag runtom på stora marknader runt i världen.
Sen har vi en internationell business som är mycket inriktad på distributörsförsäljning, framförallt mellan Österlund och Asien i den delen.
Sen har vi vår marknadsorganisation.
Man kan säga att jag är ansvarig för försäljning och marknadsföring på Eleiko.
Även om vi i svenska mått är ett ganska stort bolag i den här branschen så är vi fortfarande ett ganska litet företag.
Så det gör ju att det är breda roller på Eleiko.
Man hinner pilla på allt från produktpipeline till annat.
Men i grund och botten försäljning och marknadsföring.
Jag brukar försöka förklara det för folk utanför branschen där de säger att det går bra för gymkompagniet.
Ni är stora nu.
Nej, det finns stora pizzerier i går som omsätter mer än vad vi gör.
Det är många svårt och så var det ju med Actic också.
När man kom ihåg att man pratade mycket med investerare och så vidare.
Just att förstå att det inte är så många anläggningar som vi har av våra då i det tillfället nästan 200 anläggningar som omsätter mycket mer än 10 miljoner på stycket.
Det backar tillbaka med att kunden är beredd att betala kanske 300-500 kronor i månaden för någonting som kanske vi tycker har ett större värde.
På det sättet är det ju en konstig press i hela branschen, med allt från vilka löner som finns där till annat.
Det har många svårt att förstå, just hur ekonomin ser ut i den här branschen.
Så är det ju absolut.
Jag tänker att vi skulle göra någon liten intro om dig, och sen så gör vi någon liten intro om Eleiko, men på något sätt är det ju så att om man lyssnar på den här podden och inte vet vad Eleiko är, då kanske man bara ska googla eller...
Måste det ändå vara det mest etablerade varumärket i Sverige?
Ja, det tror jag ju faktiskt att det är.
Tror du att det finns någon som har tränat ordentligt?
Nej, tror du att det finns någon som lyssnar på den här podden som inte vet vilken är?
Jag skulle förvåna mig väldigt mycket med tanke på...
Och jag skulle också nästan vilja infrågasätta min egen med hur mycket vi har lyckats som elekter.
Med tanke på att vi är en specialist inom styrka i Sverige så har vi inte lyckats träffa din målgrupp här.
Då får vi utreda oss själva hårt.
Men låt oss då säga att ni är i alla fall premium-premium varumärket för kanske framför allt friviktsgymutrustning men ni jobbar ju lite med sidospår till det också.
Men det är väl det som är er ultranich?
Det är väl vårt ultranich.
Man kan väl säga så här att så som vi sätter det på oss är ju att vi är ett absolut premiumvarumärke och vi är en specialist inom styrka.
För oss är det tydligt att definiera, när vi går in i en kategori så satsar vi på att inom situationstekan vara bäst.
Vi går in och tittar från lyftarperspektivet eller användarperspektivet då, vad är liksom bäst, hur kan man göra den bästa produkten i den här kategorin.
Och sen är det viktigt för oss att säga att vi är styrka.
Vi är inte över hela spannet, utan vi är styrka och vi siktar på bäst och klara oss i de kategorierna vi jobbar med.
Och det är någonstans definierar ju väldigt mycket av allting som vi sen gör och inte gör i företaget.
Ja, en av mina småfrågor var om ni också beter er på det sättet inom företaget.
Har ni hela den, man får definitivt inte komma en minut för sent, man äter hälsosamt på arbetsplatsen.
Du vet, är vardagslivet i företaget lika hårt reglerat?
Jag skulle inte säga att det är hårt reglerat på det sättet, men jag skulle samtidigt, jag menar jag uppenbarligen missade vår mötesplats totalt idag, så det hade varit jobbigt att få ta den.
Men i grunden så kan man säga att de här värderingarna som ändå sitter i företaget som jag attraherar mest mycket om när jag berör det, som är performance learning kindness, jag skulle säga att de lever väldigt hårt i företaget.
Och jag skulle också säga att vi utvärderar oss efter väldigt hård ribba när det gäller alla touchpoints som finns ut i marknaden, att vi ska leva upp på varje del mot att vara det här varumärket och företaget.
Sen finns det vissa delar som jag absolut kan säga att vi, alla delar kanske, men vissa delar specifikt, där man känner att här har vi en väg upp.
Men jag skulle säga för att vara trygga med det varumärket vi har så skulle det krävas att vi verkligen har det.
Sen är det ju så, men det är ju människor här.
Nu sitter du där, du är här på en onsdag, så då kommer vi se här vid tolvtiden att det kommer att strömma ut folk i sportscentret och träna.
Så mer om att de människorna som jobbar hos oss, de är passionerade för styrka och för träning.
När jag rekryterar, framförallt i min del av organisationen, när jag rekryterar på säljare, så rekryterar jag väldigt mycket för passion, för träning och styrka specifikt.
Det har vi lärt oss också, att ska vi vara framgångsrika, så är det lite svårt att sälja den typen av produkt, om man inte är passionerad för det.
Jag brukar jämföra det med om man säljer bilar och kanske säljer Porsche.
Så gissar jag att det är ganska svårt om man inte tycker att sportbilar är ganska fäkt.
På det sättet definierar det väldigt sättad upp ribban för hur vi gör och vem vi är.
Men det låter rimligt att man ska genomsyra varumärket.
Jag tror det och jag har också sett motsatsen här, framförallt när jag började för drygt 4 år sen.
Då gjorde jag en sån här klassisk, som man ofta gör, best practice, vad lyckas vi och vad lyckas vi inte, och vad är det som gör.
Sammantaget var det ofta den vattendelaren som man kunde se, fanns det här verkligen äkta eller var det så att jag skulle kunna sälja en dammsugare eller en kia eller vad som helst, när jag rökkade vara i lek på skystängare.
Det gick inte så bra heller.
Ni har ju en ganska djup grund i Sverige.
Här vet ju alla vilka ni är.
Hur gör ni när ni går in i ett nytt land, eller kanske allra mest spännande är USA, eftersom där finns ju till exempel Rogue, och hur man går mot ett sådant etablerat varumärke.
Man kan säga att vi har en modell, men ungefär en modell kan man säga, en struktur som vi går.
Första steget för lek, det är det vi kallar nästan DNA, då är det lyftningen, powerlifting, weightlifting, framförallt och sen powerlifting, det är en liten sport i sig själv.
Men då går vi in där och försöker bygga ett starkt footprint med de organisationerna i dem.
För där har vi vår genuinaste målgrupp från början.
Sen från det så brukar vi att då börja etablera samarbeten med någon sån som vi anser är väldigt inflytelserika i marknaden.
Det kan vara en stor key account men det behöver inte vara superstor.
I UK var vi ganska tidigt inne och började jobba med Thirdspace, som är en väldigt premiumaktör och bygger varumärket.
Crossfit brukar hamna där emellan också eller funktionell fitness.
Och så bygger vi på det sättet.
Vi börjar alltid från där vi är som tryckas.
Vad är det som gör att ni lyckas slå er in där?
Vad är er usp där?
Jag tänker att det blir lätt att ta USA då för att de har rogue och alla vet vad rogue är.
Det är därför jag nämnde det.
Men när ni etablerar i USA, vad är det som gör att företag där väljer att ta in i Laco istället?
Utanför Sverige blir vi ännu tydligare ett best in class performance varumärke, nästan ännu tydligare än i Sverige.
Då tar man ofta in i Laco.
Om man bortser från tyngdlyftning och powerlifting, om man tar de här tre år som Lifetime Fitness nu, som vi gör mycket affärer med, som är en stor premiumkedja i USA, de tar in i Laco som en särskiljare.
Det bygger deras premiumposition och premiumperformance är ju ofta det man vill ha idag.
Så man vill nästan ha Laco för att bygga upp sitt eget varumärke i det.
Så det är mycket där vi kommer in.
Jag menar tar man i USA så tycker man att vi har en hög prisposition i Sverige, så blir den ju naturligt ännu högre.
Så vårt konkurrensfördel i USA är ju omvänd.
Därför att de Rogue som du nämner, och Sorenex som är stora i performancemark, de producerar i USA.
Vi ska ju producera det i Sverige, sen ska vi frakta och tulla in det i USA.
Så det gör ju att vår väg, det är ju väldigt tydligt positionerade.
Vill du ha det bästa, vill du ha någonting som ser bra ut, det är bra, det är att ha den här historien, då tar du en elek.
Det är vår enda chans att lyckas på den marknaden.
För så fort det börjar komma till, vill jag ha det som är billigast, då har vi inte så omvändig skal för konkurrensfördelar.
Kan det någonsin finnas en frustration inom organisationen att ni alltid måste ligga på den där sista procenten?
Det blir svårt att nå ut i en massmarknad eller massproducera eller...
Du fattar vad jag menar, det är ju dyrt att producera sista procenten kvalitet.
Jag tror att det kan finnas framförallt i cellledet, att man kan känna att man tappar affärer på den typen av...
Man tycker att man blir jämförd mot en annan typ av produkt.
Sen skulle jag säga att mer och mer under de åren...
Jag skulle säga att den utmaningen som nu störst uppfattar jag för då kanske fyra år sedan när jag började.
Nu skulle jag nästan säga att det börjar komma till att den tydligheten nästan hjälper oss för det någonstans talar om att vi letar efter en kund som uppskattar där vi kan skapa en vinnar-vinna-konstellation och som dels uppskattar från perspektivet performanceen av utrustningen, men som också tänker kvalitet.
Vi har ju många rätt så stora kedjor som köper Eleco idag och de köper ju en del av många, såklart varumärket är viktigt, men del är också att man faktiskt tänker total cost of ownership i det här, att priset när jag köper produkten nu, det är det här, men man behöver faktiskt räkna på att kan jag ha den här skivstången i 25 år istället för tre, så blir det faktiskt ett högre värde i den.
Så jag skulle säga att ibland kan det absolut tacka att det finns myggas in den, men i grunden så tror jag att den har hjälpt på oss också att skapa en tydlighet, att kunna vara transparenta.
Att uppskattar du det vi erbjuder, då är vi för dig, men gör du inte det, då ska vi förmodligen inte göra affärer tillsammans.
Vi pratar väldigt mycket om vinnar-vinna-modellen internt.
Vi har ett stort krav på oss, att vi måste skapa värde.
Det är sällan vi kommer gå in i en affär och kunden kommer tillbaka och säger att ni var absolut billigast, så vi gick på er.
Det är sällan det.
Däremot kommer man många gånger att säga att ni skapade störst värde.
Det är där tricket ligger för oss, att vi måste skapa så stort värde och kunden måste uppleva det värdet.
Då får man vinnar-vinna i det.
Däremot skulle man kanske kunna tänkt sig att vi ökar rabatten i stället för att vinna den.
Då blir det inget jämlikt förhållande i den.
Det kräver mer, det kan vara en frustration på sitt sätt, samtidigt har det här också gjort det tydligare och enklare för oss vilka vi är och var vi ska vara.
Tittar man då framför allt internationellt, vi skulle aldrig vinna den matchen.
Det är väldigt många av alla företag i Sverige som vi hade exporterat till USA och gått upp mot dem, så hade man förlorat i vilket fall.
Ja exakt.
Men jag vet, nu var väl detta ett tag sedan, men jag hörde en podd med Erik tror jag för ett par år sedan att ni vann någon amerikansk militärupphandling eller något sånt.
Stämmer.
Det måste ju varit en oerhörd process.
Men det var det, nu hände det.
Det hände precis innan jag började, men i grunden så var det ju så här att vi kom in där på grund av utbildning.
Vi vann ju en upphandling för US Navy-utbildning.
Från det så tvingade det ju oss att skaffa kompetens kring hur funkar den här, liksom, bisten, får man väl säga, som US military är med när det gäller upphandling.
Då fick vi ju in människor som kunde den här och lyckades då också via utbildningsdelen ta oss in och då finnas med en utrustning för amerikanska militären.
Så det är en väldigt, vad ska man säga, en väldigt speciell, tycker vi, upphandling i Sverige är komplext.
Så upphandling här är ju någonting helt annat.
Och så finns det ju så många olika, mycket politik inriknat här.
Även om vi tycker att politiker kanske kan blanda sig här, så är det ju ingenting något hur det är i USA där det är liksom uttalat.
Kan liksom finnas, styra om upphandling ska inte se ut i det.
Och vi har ju kollegor i branschen som är helt inriktade på upphandling som kanske då även gör mer än utrustning utan även bygger andra delar för dem som till och med de har personal anställda runt dem som bor utanför baserna runt om i USA, runt om i världen för att liksom aktivt kunna jobba med de här kontrakten.
Så det är ju någonting helt annat.
Så mycket gör inte vi kan man väl säga i det utan vi ser det mycket.
Vi har människor anställda för det vi jobbar mot dem och sen ser vi väldigt mycket kopplingen till att när vi jobbar med utbildning och utbildar hur man ska träna soldaterna har vi skapat också koncept för dem hur man bygger en performance anläggning för det var en stor del av det vi gjorde för dem egentligen.
Man började ju egentligen med att man ändrade testerna för amerikanska soldater till att det blev mer styrkebaserat.
Det innebär att utbildningen av dem behövde ändras och slutändan blev nästa steg.
Då måste man också ändra hur man byggde anläggningar.
Från början såg många av de anläggningar för att se ut som en vanlig svensk träningsanläggning.
Problemet blir att om du skickar in 25 amerikanska Navy Seals där som ska köra mycket lyftning, så är det ju inte så att i Sverige tycker vi det är lite jobbigt att alla flyttar de funktionella ärlutrustning till Strettsjöyten och skapar en funktionell där flyttar man utrustning istället.
Vi byggde ju den här som vi kallar Strength Stations.
Det var egentligen där det konceptet började fås där man började titta på hur kan man skapa så att man kan göra all sin funktionella styrketräning på ett ställe.
Och så skapar vi de koncepten till det.
Men allting började egentligen då med testen har ändrade så vi kom in på utbildningen och sen började vi skapa värde för dem.
Så egentligen samma process som med vilken krum som helst, men väldigt mycket mer komplex.
Har ni alltid haft den här utbildningsdelen?
Det finns ju, jag jobbade ju och drev ett gym för och då var det ju många som hade gått i era utbildningar och sådant där.
Men är det ett passionsprojekt eller finns det en tanke bakom det?
Det kan inte vara en stor del av era omsättning.
Nej men så här är det ju, att utbildning har funnits med länge i bilden för oss.
Och i grunden i utbildningen från början, om jag kan historien rätt det där, var ju faktiskt just att utbilda branscher nästan om friviksträning och lyftning.
För eleiker var ju väldigt nischade.
Man kan ju säga att även om utbildningen får sig viktiga, att den har en specifik ägare, vi vill göra det med hög standard, så syftet för oss som utbildning är fortfarande egentligen att sprida kunskap om funktionell träning och lyftning och att skapa värde till våra kunder och branschen kring det.
Det är inte det stället som vi säger att det är här vi ska tjäna pengar om man ska vara kasset, utan den egentligen fyller fortfarande den funktionen.
För grund och botten är det så att en skivstång är ju, oavsett vem som har sålt den, en vit stål ända tills den används.
Så att den...
Men vi ser verkligen vikten och det är också, du frågade innan, just när vi går in i nymarknad, utbildning är en stor del som jag glömde nämna där, som vi faktiskt jobbar med.
Vi jobbar just nu väldigt mycket i Mellanöstern och där kommer utbildningskomponenten ganska fort in att utbilda allt från kunden, tränare, gymägaren, men också i det här fallet våra distributörer om styrketräning.
Okej, okej.
Hur stor, nu nämner du Mellanöstern, men hur stor del är Sverige kontra Norden, kontra världen?
Har du någon koll på procent ungefär?
Sverige är ju ungefär 15 procent av vår omsättning.
Den internationella sidan av affären har ju växt, även om Sverige har växt ganska bra, så har den internationella sidan av affären växt mycket fortare under de sista åren.
Så merparten av vår utrustning går faktiskt på exportnivå.
Men skickas allt från Hamstead?
Allt skickas från Hamstead.
Sen så har vi en distributionshub i Texas, i Åstin.
Så att när vi levererar i USA så kommer det mesta att ha direkt...
att levereras ut från Åstin.
Sen har vi en del produkter då som går direkt från Lantör till Åstin.
Så att det är en viss aning modifikation men i grund och bort en ja.
Okej.
Och anledningen till att ni satte där är det för att den amerikanska marknaden är stor eller är det för att ni tror att den ska bli stor?
Vi tror att den...
Nej men den är stor för oss just nu men det är fortfarande...
Är den större än den svenska?
Den är lite större än den svenska i dag.
Den är större än den svenska i dag men vi ser ju att potentialen är större i den.
Vi hade en tredjepartslösning tidigare i USA men vi kände att ska vi lyckas ta del av den här potentialen som vi ändå ser så får vi stoppa ner flaggan här och verkligen testa det.
Så att den amerikanska marknaden har växt ganska fort de sista åren och gått förbi den svenska ganska så rejält.
Jag tänker det har ju hänt ganska mycket senaste åren, både i krig och corona och allt sånt där men vi har ju också gått igenom en ganska digital utveckling som har hänt under lång tid.
Och det som min mamma till exempel skulle känna en leiko på är ju OS.
Och jag tänker att det var Sommars Sintes förut, det var då man visade att vi är bäst.
Och det är väl fortfarande ni som har det.
Men nu för tiden görs ju inte reklam på det sättet, utan det är ju mycket mer tusen-nål-stick än vad det är ett stort event.
Skulle du kunna förklara lite hur ni jobbar med ert varumärke nu kontra för 20 år sedan, även om du inte var med för 20 år sedan i den här.
Men du fattar, förr var det kanske mer kontakter, den här utbildningen går alla, och nu är det väldigt fragmenterat.
Tänk om det hade varit så enkelt.
Det kändes i alla fall som att det var enklare, men det var det förmodligen inte.
Men tänk om det hade varit så.
Nej men i grunden så var, generellt när det gäller hela den här utvecklingen av varumärket, så för oss är det viktigt att följa den produktportföljen ganska tydligt.
Så vi säger att produkten är en väldigt stor bärare av varumärket hela tiden.
Och det skulle man säga att det växer nästan hela tiden.
Den får oss att hela tiden se produkten som nästan den största varumärkesbäraren som vi har.
Hur menar du med det?
Det är designspråket som vi jobbar med.
Att verkligen titta på att vi jobbar med det vi säger från lyfta hans perspektiv.
Att upplevelsen av den, jag brukar jämföra den här med att den stänger någons bild i bilddörr så känner du den här dova, mjuka, fina smälande som någon annan så samlar det.
Alla de där touchpointsen med en elekoprodukt bygger ju varumärket.
Och det blir ju det sättet som man också kanske kan kontrollera att alla de här micro-influencers, alla som provar dem, alla som pratar om det, alla som postar något, att man någonstans försöker göra att den upplevelsen när jag kommer i kontakt med en elekoprodukt är konsistent.
Det blir ju en...
Jag hör att du pratar engelska till vardags.
Ja, det blir ganska mycket engelska till vardags.
Men den blir ju central i den världen som vi lever i, eftersom det går inte att kontrollera alla som pratar om det.
Sen har vi gjort ett antal lärdomar de senaste åren.
Det ena som har gjort det är att vi har centraliserat alla våra sociala medier nu.
Vi jobbar med en...
Från och med någon gång i december jobbar vi med en kanal på ett utvalda socialmedier.
Tidigare hade vi även lokala, men vi har ju någonstans lätt oss också.
Det är också kopplat till varumärket, att vi måste ha kontroll på så mycket som möjligt av vår kommunikation.
Jag tror att alla har sett den här heavy mag som gjorde en gång hur mycket...
Vi blev chockade själva av mycket spridning vi fick med Eleko och det talar om för oss, vikten av oss, att faktiskt ha kontroll på vår kommunikation.
För att går det snett så kan det gå snett rejält i den.
Sen kommer det tillbaka till att vi måste vara trygga i att vi levererar i alla hatchpoints mot kundomarknad.
Det man förväntar sig av Eleko som företag, som produkt, att det är det man får.
Om man har ett problem att man inte är nöjd med sin produkt, att man känner att man blir bemött och förstådd i den.
Och att vi är äkta rakt igenom.
Jag tror att det är nog det vi har landat i.
Produkten, äktheten, att verkligen säkra att vi har koll på våra kommunikationskanaler i marknadsföringen.
Och att det blir viktigare och viktigare för att Eleko som varumärke ska kännas äkta och finnas där.
Så det blir nästan en lite tråkig svar, men det är väldigt mycket av de bar-sakerna.
Nej men det är väl rimligt.
Ni gjorde ju en stor förändring här under corona som kanske delvis drevs av att man sålde mycket mer via e-handel, men då tog ni ju hem väldigt mycket försäljning.
Innan hade ni ju många OF och då blir det ju många touchpoints som ni inte kan kontrollera som du säger.
Men då tog ni hem en stor del av det och byggde om era sajt, höra för mig.
Och den blev jävligt clean och snyggt, får man säga, trots att vi är ett typ konkurrent.
Ja, både och.
Men den blev i alla fall jävligt läcker.
Hur gick det från att vara, även om en stor del av er var direkt försäljning, men ni var ju ändå till viss del en grossist och där blev ni direkt försäljning mot privatkund.
Hur blev det att hantera den ruschen av privatkunder?
Jag kan backa den lite grann.
Vi hade lite tur att vi någonstans innan pandemin hade förberett oss för att vi ändå ville ha en egen kanal.
Så vi hade någonstans börjat bygga en hel del grundarbete innan.
Tänkte det, för ni var jävligt snabba.
Vi var väldigt snabba.
Sen såklart, då blev det en snabb spolning när det här hände.
Vi har tur att vi har ju TechDevelopment internt, så vi kunde vara snabba.
Men precis som du sa på din fråga, så är det klart att det går från att driva ett antal stora order om dagen, att packa och skeppa och hantera och så vidare, till att helt plötsligt så har du 500 små order om dagen som ska rullas i systemet, med allt vad det innebär.
För du vet ju också, som var den, att när man jobbar med privatpersoner så blir det bakändan av det du har sålt blir det så mycket större för du köper en produkt och den produkten ska vara perfekt, vilket den ska vara.
Och du får lika många frågor på den produkten som är helt gymmen.
Precis.
Det är klart att du fick en overload på alla delar av det.
Vi hade satt ett litet kundsupportteam på det, men det är klart att det var väldigt intensivt.
Vi fick någonstans att rekvirera folk från kontoret som sitter här och packar ordrar när det var mest intensivt där för att lyckas med det.
Men väldigt nyttigt för oss också, vi hade aldrig ambitionen om att e-handel skulle bli vår största.
Vi ser att e-handeln är en kanal för oss, där vi kan gå ut till en målgrupp såklart.
Men det var väldigt nyttigt för oss i förhållande till att få den här direktkontakten med slutanvändaren av vår produkt på ett annat sätt än vad du kanske får när du bara är ett B2B-företag.
Bara ur det perspektivet så har det fått oss att höja oss på ett antal områden.
Är e-handeln någonting som faktiskt växer eller är det mer konstant och gör ni det i alla länder?
Vi har inte e-handel i alla länder.
Den växer inte för oss inom större uttryck.
Utan det vi gör är att vi fokuserar våra e-handel på de produkterna som vi anser är relevanta för e-handel.
Det som växer för oss däremot när det gäller det segmentet är den som vill bygga som ett riktigt hemmagym och satsa.
Vi gör ju, vilket vi gör på ett antal delar runt om i världen där vi bygger.
Det segmentet växer för oss på ett väldigt bra sätt.
Medan e-handel, det är en ganska stabil nivå, men samtidigt har vi också smalnat det sortimentet.
Vi gör det primärt i Europa och i USA.
Inte alla marknader i Europa.
Okej, ni säljer inte hela sortimentet på e-handeln?
Ja, det gör vi inte.
Du som är i den här världen vet att vissa av de här produkterna är ju inte så faktvänliga.
Va?
Ingen av de här produkterna är faktvänliga?
Nej, det finns de som är ännu mindre faktvänliga.
Och likadant att vissa produkter, nu har vi gjort ett rätt så stort tryck i vår produktutveckling med det vi kallar presterasystemet, som är ett modellärt system.
Vi gjorde tester, vi gjorde ambitioner att man gör lite som rogue, att man skulle bygga det själv som kunder.
Men apropå en jobb i bakgrunden, att du fick en dålig kundupplevelse, så valde vi att i de fall som man faktiskt vill ha det så är det bättre att man gör det via en person och så gör vi det tillsammans och ritar och bygger upp det.
Så där av valde vi att vissa produkter som vi har i vårt sortiment blir inte en bra kundupplevelse när vi driver det via e-handel.
Det finns säkert de som gör det väldigt bra med det, men vi bedömde att det inte är det vi gör bäst.
Jag tror att man underskattar hur mycket man själv lever in i den här världen.
Vi på något sätt ser det varje dag.
Det här är inte så komplicerat, det är bara att lägga till det här.
Men för en person som är helt ny inom det så är det helt hopplöst.
Hopplöst, så tittar man då in på vårt presterasystem och så är det inte hur många olika komponenter där.
Där var ju fler felbyggda riggar och racks som vi sålde, men det var som var rätt exakt så att vi har smalnat ner, där finns ett antal standardkomponenter som man kan köpa såklart.
Men sen så ser vi också att där vi som touchpoint, där vi ska vara duktiga, som den aktör vi är, är ju verkligen att guida kunden till den bästa lösningen.
Så vi vill gärna få sitta med kunden och rita ut det.
Kanske i stor gym vara ut och mäta och ta foton och göra hela den här upplevelsen till en premiumupplevelse.
Det är tror jag att att leva upp till var vi är så är det en viktig del.
Kan du nästan se på vår hemsida att vi styr nästan till personlig interaktion.
Vi har nästan tagit ett omvänd grepp mot vad många gör.
Vi vill göra det enkelt och komma i kontakt med oss.
Snarare när vissa sajter som man är inne på, jag vet kanske inte just vår bransch, men vissa andra branscher som man försöker hitta någon att prata med, det är helt omöjligt.
Nej men absolut och det stämmer.
Även i vår bransch skulle jag säga.
Men jag tycker att det låter sunt.
Gör ni den personliga kontakten i alla länder?
Där vi...
Och vart har ni folk på plats?
Kanske man ska säga, vart har ni sidokontor eller folk som pratar lokala språk?
Vi har sidokontor, stora marknaderna i Europa, så det är Tyskland, Frankrike, Spanien, England, Benedux har vi, har vi teckning i Norge, Finland, Sverige...
Jag skulle fråga hur alla länder ni inte hade.
Vi har vi inte.
Men tar man...
Det som skiljer för oss är väl när man...
Vi har numera så har vi bemanning, fast att de mesta försäljningarna faktiskt vi har distributörer i Mellanöstern.
Och vi håller just nu på att etablera och rekrytera mer, liksom mer boots on the ground i delar av Asien, men också distributörsförsäljning.
Så man kan säga framförallt Europa, USA och kanske nu Mellanöstern, där kan vi liksom ge den här direkta och jobba via våra, och sen blir det distributörer på de andra.
Där har vi också lärt oss nu under apropå kontroll på våra kanal.
Vi upplever att det finns så mycket mer att man kan göra när man jobbar med distributören, vad som gjorts i den här branschen.
Många gör det, vissa gör det kanske bra, men de vi har sett, där det lätt blir att man någonstans, man pratar en gång om året så kommer man överens om att du ska sälja så här mycket, och här är vår prislista, och sen så eventuellt ringer man och hör av sig om man inte tycker att man har sålt tillräckligt.
Men vi ser ju, apropå utbildning, marknadsmaterial, den delen, att vi lägger ett rätt stort arbete nu på att verkligen hellre supportera och utveckla våra distributörer så att de ska känna sig Liko i det vi gör och få en betydligt mer aktivt arbete för att verkligen kunna förmedla den här Likos upplevelsen även via en distributör.
Men är de brandade i Liko utomlands eller är de en egen?
De är en egen.
Vi har valt att vi delar inte ut varumärket.
Nu har du nämnt Mellanöstern ett par gånger.
Hur kommer det sig att ni är uppskattade där eller att ni kommer in där starkt?
Det känns ju inte som den första marknaden man går på.
Nej, det kanske inte är den första så.
Det vi säger är att styrkesporten är väldigt uppskattad i den regionen, vilket gör att det finns en grundkännedom om Eleko.
Sen märker man också att det här med att köpa det som är bäst det attraheras av i den såklart.
Sen finns det just nu en underliggande ekonomisk driv mot en motor i den regionen som överlaggör att branschen utvecklas och för att samhället utvecklas kanske också.
Men det gör ju att där det finns, så jag var nere i Dubai i december och var på Dubai Active där.
Där märkte man tillsammans med Odisto Betar och hur många som kommer verkligen och bara kan säga att vi älskar era produkter, vi älskar Eleiko.
Jag var ju chockad någonstans.
Jag åkte dit och tänkte att folk kanske inte ens vet vem vi är, utan tvärt om hur många som kommer att säga det.
Det tror jag baserar sig på egentligen att styrkesporten har ganska stark rota och att man faktiskt uppskattar och vill ha bra grejer.
Du nämner ju Eleiko, det är ju som du säger ett varumärke som nästan drar upp kvalitén lite när man förknippar sig med det.
Vi sålde till exempel Eleiko för tre år sedan, innan corona i alla fall.
Då var ju det en sådan grej att folk kunde komma in på grund av det varumärket och känna att det här är en legit hemsida för de säljer Eleiko.
Ni har ju fortfarande enstaka återförsäljare och vad är det som gör att ni ändå väljer att sälja via den kanalen där ni inte har full kontroll på varumärket?
Det är en bra fråga och det här fanns en historik, det är inte säkert vanligt men det fanns en historik där vi hade en återförsäljare som hade satsat ganska hårt på oss, köpt ganska mycket och ganska stor omsättning.
När vi började göra det här jobbet så kom pandemin in i den här och då var det så enkelt att vi kände att vi inte kan göra så här mot någon som har satsat så mycket på oss.
Vi stänger samarbetet, stänger dörren och sen så...
Då kände vi att vi sätter upp ett ganska tydligt regelverk hur vi kan hantera varandra och så låter vi det rulla.
Sen har vi låtit det rullan på sen dess kan man säga.
Det var egentligen en ganska orationell anledning kopplat till att vi är ganska kliniska i vissa fall så var han väldigt mycket att det där inte är riktigt fair att göra på det viset.
Okej, det var rimligt.
Och hur går det...
Ni säljer ju en del andra varumärken.
Ni hade ju en annan maskinserie tidigare och nu tog ni väl in Precore?
Om jag inte misstänker mig för typ två år sen eller något.
Det är nog rätt exakt för oss när det kan stämma.
Ett och ett halvt kan stämma.
Ni säljer väl lite Concept skulle jag gissa?
Ja, det är jag väl alla.
Det är ingen som tjänar pengar på det men alla säljer det.
Så är det definitivt.
Vad är det som har gjort att ni har valt de varumärkena och vad är problematiken med att sälja ett annat varumärke än ett era när ni är huvudvarumärket?
Det man kanske ska börja med att säga där är att vi kallar det partnerbrands och vi gör det bara i Norden.
Anledningen har varit att man har kunnat från början.
Eftersom vi är i Sverige, vi har nätverket, vi har distributörcentraler och så vidare så kan vi vara en duktig distributör i det.
Så det har någonstans funnits där.
Sen egentligen de sista 3-4 åren så gick vi från en portfölj som var väldigt bred där man gjorde en liten klassisk distributör, att man ville ha så många varumärken som möjligt för att kunna erbjuda kunden.
Då gick vi egentligen emot och så sa vi att vi ska smalna.
Vi ska ha en smal och väldigt tydlig och det måste vara varumärken där vi ser att det här kan hänga ihop på något sätt med vad vi står för som eleko.
Då landade det med Precorollarius som vi har just nu.
Sen har vi Woodway i portföljen.
Sen har vi Golv.
Och så har vi lite concept som du säger, men det är ju någonstans man är erbjuden för att kunden vill ha det snarare än att man aktivt säljer det.
Det är definitivt en utmaning i hur man, från ett Eleco-perspektiv, hur bygger man det här i det?
För Eleco är ett väldigt tydligt varumärke.
Det är ett varumärke där vi tydligt kommunicerar till slut användaren av lyftan vi pratar om, som vi bygger med, vi har vår community.
Om man tar pre-core eller även skulle vi säga techno-gym eller live-fitness eller vem det nu kan vara, så har man historiskt inte kommunicerat särskilt mycket till slut användaren.
Det är inte särskilt många som skulle köpa ett gymmkort och säga va, har ni inte techno-gym löpande eller har ni inte pre-core löpande?
Det sitter inte där på det sättet.
Så det blir en helt annan typ av produkt att jobba med än vad Eleco gör.
Men det som var viktigt med pre-core för oss var kvalitetsaspekterna.
De är väldigt starka, de kommer egentligen från att de är en duktig producent, de är duktig produktutvecklare, de älskar att lyfta på huvudet och skruva och tänka på att utrustningen är enkel att serva och den ska hålla länge.
Och den funkar bra för oss för att vi är en av grundhusparna för Eleco, det är kvalitet.
Så det går ihop på det sättet.
Och Woodway likadant, de är ju lite best in class på löpning, det är de väldigt skarpa på.
Vi har byggt det som en best in class portfölj, i att vi ska någonstans bäst i respektive kategori i det vi gör.
Sen har vi Atlantis som vi jobbat med i Storvre, som vi egentligen tyckte också var ett bra varumärke för oss att jobba med, men rent på grund av hur de är svåra att jobba med för oss ifrån så väldigt långa ledtider, så därför har vi tonat ner dem lite och blivit med.
Men de var också som vi uppfattade ett best in class, för de var väldigt tydligt in på styrkemaskiner och hade sin historia i det.
Så har vi positionerat och byggt portföljen för att det ska hänga ihop med det, men inte utan utmaning kan man säga.
Ja, nu ser ju inte folk hur det ser ut, men du flynnar.
Vad finns det för utmaningar med att jobba med andra varumärken jämfört med CTG?
Det är ju att du äger ju inte, vi kan ju inte, alltså vår DNA, vår logik är att det måste vara viktigt för slutanvändaren att de känner till eleiko, de vill ha eleiko, de nästan skriker på sitt gym att ni ska ha eleiko.
Det ska finnas en emotionell koppling till varumärket.
Det är svårt för oss om inte de partner som vi jobbar med vill göra det jobbet och har gjort det i hoppet genom åren för att sätta det i varumärket.
Så blir det lätt att det blir, kan man kalla den, det kan inte komma ut fel men det blir en commodity-försäljning nästan, vilket är precis omvänd det sättet som vi jobbar med eleiko där vi försöker, det är en värdeförsäljning i den.
Så mycket är att vi kontrollerar inte deras varumärkeshistoria, vi kontrollerar inte deras produktutveckling i den skulle jag för att blå vara ägare på Icair, så hade jag byggt det till det bästa cardio-brandet i världen.
Därför att det har de potential att vara egentligen, det kanske de är också egentligen, snarare än att vi gör det här också.
Jag fattar.
Är prestera-serien er första steg mot att bygga en egen maskin-serie?
Oj, förlöver svara på den.
Jag säger så här, att vår ambition är att vi ska vara the number one strength company.
Och med det sagt så tror jag att det också svarar på våra ambitioner när det gäller styrka.
Men ni har inga tankar på, det kan man ju såklart inte säga för framtiden, men ni har inte funderat på att flötta lite med konditionsvärlden och ta in den sortens utrustning.
Det ligger längre ifrån liksom.
Nej, vi är väldigt tydliga.
För oss är det viktigt att ha den här särskildningen, att vi är styrka.
Det är det vi har passion för, det är det vi har kompetens för, det är det vi är erotade för.
Det är också det som folk känner sig trygga med när man jobbar med Lekos.
Så vi har varit väldigt tydliga att det är styrka och sen så är snarare frågan då hur brett kan styrkebegreppet bli för oss?
Och sen kan man också säga att en del av de här kategorierna i varje kategori som vi går in på så tittar vi också på vad är best in class?
Vad är det vi behöver slå här för att vi faktiskt ska kunna gå in och göra det bästa?
Och det är lite den förväntanfolk som man har på Eleco när vi går in.
Och det är också utmaningen när man ska bredda då.
Vi kan inte bara ta våra, då kommer det att se ut i Sportscentrum att våra precom-maskiner där och så bara byter vi lådan som vissa varumärken har gjort och sätter Eleco på.
Då kommer vi dra ner hela varumärkets känslan.
Vi måste ju göra någonting som i det här fallet nästan innoverar hela kategorin skulle jag säga.
Är det det som är målet varje gång ni går in i en ny produkt?
Absolut är det det och det är det som också kanske håller oss tillbaka med vilket tempo man kan göra saker med.
Vi anser att vi går in och gör någonting så måste vi lyfta kategorin på något sätt.
Annars så ska vi inte göra det.
Det är en spännande tanke.
Jag gillar den tanke men det är som du säger, det kanske inte är ett private equity case.
Men det är en 50-års business case med någonting som bygger värde.
Jag gillar det för det skapar tydlighet i det vi gör och det sätter krav på oss själva.
Om vi har små appar på varumärken så är det viktigt för att om vi inte gör det så lanserar vi någonting som är halvpissigt.
Då kommer det att spilla över på det vi faktiskt är och bortar.
Hur gör ni med att följa upp era egna produkter?
Alltså utveckla era egna produkter och ta fram nya versioner?
Har ni den här skivstången, jobbar ni med att utveckla den?
Eller är det en version och sen gör ni en ny skivstång som är en annan?
Hur tänker man?
Det är lite olika.
Det sker att det finns ett antal olika processer.
Det finns hela tiden en pågående förbättringsarbete där vi hela tiden tar in feedback för kvalitetsproblem.
Tar man sådant produkt som skivstången testar vi den hela tiden.
Det sker kontinuerande testande av det.
Det kan ske små förbättringar, förändringar som kanske som du som kunde kanske inte ens märker.
Men för oss är skivstången en väldigt teknisk produkt.
Vi har kollegor i branschen som kan se det som att det bara handlar om hur hårt det stålet eller hur länge.
Men för oss är skivstången väldigt teknisk.
Där finns det väldigt mycket små fintunande man kan göra.
Men samtidigt pågår det hela tiden ett projekt där man då, om vi då ska komma, när den nya generationen skivstång ska komma som lyfter upp nivån ytterligare en gång till, så pågår de spåren parallellt kan man säga i det hela tiden.
Vissa produkter som framför allt skivstånger och viktskivor där finns alltid ett produktutvecklingsarbete på två nivåer.
Ett som är småsma förbättringar och ett som är nästa steg upp på skalan.
Ja, men har ni sådana basprodukter som har samma varumärke men som är helt annorlunda idag än för 20 år sedan?
Säg en viktskiva som är för styrkelyft.
Kan du se skillnad på den idag och den för 10 år sedan trots att det är samma artikelnummer?
Hade man som lekman kunnat se det?
Ja det hade du kunnat nu i den.
Och det är återigen, den versionen som vi säljer just nu, där finns det delförändringar i färger och så vidare, på hållbarheten men sen finns det också som man har sett en bättre greppkant i den.
Ja det är ju hopplöst på de gamla.
Det där är en nice förbättring.
Hopplöst på de andra, för att man ska lyfta.
Så det är så det har det sett.
Så att hela tiden, om man kan säga för oss, det är lite vår bransch när vi pratar om innovation.
Man ska ju alltid vara ödmjuk för innovation i vår bransch och så tittar man innovation i andra branscher.
Men det sättet som vi gör, det är väldigt mycket att titta från användarperspektivet.
Okej, hur kan man göra det här bättre?
Tar man presterasystemet så var det sådana här små delar som att vi testade faktiskt, från varandra serie och runt om, vad är optimalt avstånd mellan benen när du ska racka i och racka ur?
Och så fick vi börja labba med storleken på gods, på rören.
Och eftersom vi fick gå ner i dimensioner, då fick vi också börja med att godset vara tjockare, för annars tycker vi inte att den är lika stabil.
Och så blev det liksom, och innovationen blev för oss väldigt mycket från, hur gör vi styrketräning bättre för lyftaren?
Och då kan det vara, kan ju också vara som den här öppen kloven som du kanske sett när du såg ut i...
Vi har kontakt.
Den var ju mycket för att göra lyftning mer tillgänglig.
För vi fick in mycket feedback från gymmen, att många lyftare hade nästan...
De var nästan jobbigare att sätta på kloven än vad de hade att egentligen lyfta i den.
Och då hittar man, men hur kan vi innoveras så att det här momentet blir bättre?
Och det är väl det det handlar om, kanske var en specialist.
Att man faktiskt tittar på de där små små detaljerna från lyftaren.
Men med det sagt då så innovation då blir ju i förhållande till iPhone 3 till iPhone 15 så kanske det är en liten skillnad.
Men det är det sättet som vi angripade på ofta.
När i resan börjar ni fundera på prissättning?
För ni är ju ändå ett dyrare varumärke och tar man...
Mer prissvärt.
Tar man ens?
Det är bra, helt rätt.
Okej, ni är ett dyrare prissvärt varumärke.
Men när börjar man komma in med prissättningen i utvecklingsledet?
Har man med det eller fokuserar man helt på att nu ska vi ta fram en bättre produkt?
Jag bara tänker på hur mycket tänker man på pris eller inte?
Den finns med redan från start.
Att vi någonstans sätter en målbild på vad vi behöver träffa för att vara relevanta.
För det är klart att du kan ju prisa ut dig ur en kategori genom att det inte spelar ingen roll hur mycket bättre du är.
Så har du prisat ut dig.
Så vi sätter ett målpris egentligen innan.
Och det sättet som vi gör ofta i det här är att vi lägger ett rätt så stort arbete in i början av utvecklingsprocessen där vi också tittar på hur man använder kundenprodukten.
Hur vill man använda den?
Vad finns det egentligen?
Vad saknar man med de produkter som finns på marknaden?
Vad skulle man vara beredd att betala hela det?
Så vi gör ganska gediget arbete.
Jag skulle säga det blir gedigna och gedignare nu allt eftersom åren går.
Och det vi märkte är omgångarna som vi hamnar fel.
För det händer ju faktiskt i vissa lägen att vi kommer ganska långt i vår produktutvecklingsfas och sen så bara scrapar vi det.
Du vill ju helt köra att jag kommer att ställa frågan.
Har du något exempel på någon sån som du får berätta?
Det finns både en hantel och en viktskiva som inte kommit ut på marknaden som vi scrapar.
Och egentligen då, precis av det vi skojar lite om, att vi ser att värdet av den här produkten det vi lyckats utveckla det fyller inte det priset vi behöver ta.
Eller alternativt att vi faktiskt inte hittat det som vi en gång förstod var en utmaning eller som vi kunde göra bättre för en användare.
Vi har inte hittat det tillräckligt bra.
Och då väljer man, det är jäkligt smärtsamt att göra det för det finns ju någon som faktiskt en produktchef och ett team som har lagt massa tid på det där.
Och så kommer man fram och så säger vi bara att det här förstärker årenten så släng prototyperna av verktygen och så där.
Men det händer att vi hamnar där och då är det ofta, då har vi inte gjort del 1 i produktutvecklingsfasen tillräckligt bra.
Vi har inte rotat oss tillräckligt bra från början och då hamnar man fel.
Jag tänker att jag ska säga till alla som lyssnar att när du säger slängverktygen, det är inte två skiftnycklar man slänger utan det är dyra grejer man slänger.
Det är hundratusentals kronor som går upp.
Vi har gjort några sådana där omgångar också.
Det är lätt.
Jag ska också säga att jag fattar att det är just den produkten som blev så, för att hantlar måste vara vår bransch tråkigaste produkt, för den är såpass dyr, kontra vad kunden ser.
En skivstång, om era en snittskivstång kostar 10 000, det känns rimligt, men om man köper två par hantlar som är 30 kilo, 40 kilo, så är det också där någonstans, jag gissar era genrer.
Det känns inte rimligt för kunden, men det är ju det det kostar.
Hantlar är fruktansvärt dyrt.
Ja, det är det ju för att du har monterings tiden på en hantel, det är inte hemskt mycket kortare än vad det är på en skivstång.
Sen är det lite mindre material och så vidare.
Så är det ju och vi.
Det kanske är ännu svårare i vissa segment i marknaden att göra en hantel som vi uppskattar tillräckligt mycket för att du ska vilja betala någonting.
Det är verkligen så.
Sen kan man förvånas att vår Evo-hantel, som är verkligen en premium-hantel, som är verkligen best in class, som man har till och med provat så länge redan från ett högt karage en gång i tiden i USA, och det funkar det.
Den har satt sig på många delar.
Så tar man internationellt så säljer den.
Så är folk verkligen beredda att betala för den hanteln, för att den ger så pass mycket mer.
Men det kommer tillbaka till det du sa, skulle du bara pressa hanteln, körla hanteln, ro hanteln, då kanske det inte blir värt det kanske, men vill du kunna göra mer, då blir det sant.
Men det är en svårprodukt definitivt.
Sedan tänkte jag se lite här om du kan hänga ut, jag har några frågor kvar.
Jag tänkte se om du kan hänga ut någon av dina kolleger, inte den som är sämst, utan vem är liksom mister eller missis i lejko, vem är det som går runt och rättar alla som missköter sig, och inte fyller varumärket?
I grund och botten tror jag att det är en del där som jag hoppas att du nu får uppleva när du gör en eget nevisit på lejko.
Jag skulle säga att just den här kulturen och värderingen, att den finns rätt så mycket hos många människor på lejko som jobbar, att man faktiskt gör det själv.
Men sen skulle jag nog ändå säga att här kommer vi tillbaka till det familjeägda företaget, där Erik Blomberg som är vd och del av ägda familjen, han har ju en väldigt hög ribba för hur vi ska agera, hur vi ska prestera och hur vi ska...
Jag skulle säga att han är ju Mr.
Eleko på det sättet, om man ska ta en person.
Det finns ju nog få personer som kan så mycket detalj om styrketräningsutrustning som Erik, som är inne och synar precis varenda liten detalj i en Eleko-produkt som kommer att gå ut till en kund.
Det som passerar hans öga, det har fått en rejäl quality-kontroll, kan man väl säga.
Jag förstår.
Är det jobbigt när han står och tittar bakom axeln?
Jag skulle inte säga att det är jobbigt, utan det är inspirerande skulle jag nu säga.
Det kräver att man själv är betonad.
Och det kommer just det här, performance and learning.
Man måste vara ödmjuk för att hela tiden utvecklas och bli bättre.
Det tror jag är nästan, ska man vara ett växande företag, att ha människor som växer med det, det tror jag är den största utmaningen.
Absolut.
Har du några tips till alla därute som har ett företag, säger att de har ett gym eller de driver en PT-firma eller vad de nu gör, utrustning.
Hur stärker man sitt varumärke?
Hur får man den här i leko?
Om man inte kan sponsra OS.
Hur gör man i modern tid för att bygga sitt varumärke?
Jag tror att den första delen är lite tråkiga svar kanske, men den första delen är att rota sig i vem är jag till för?
Vem är det jag vill se som min kund och som jag vill kommunicera och vågar välja bort?
Jag säger inte i leko att vi väljer bort någon, vi vill ju att alla ska vilja ha lekoprodukter, men samtidigt är vi väldigt tydliga med att vi kommer att ge den bästa psyketrädningsprodukten, vi kommer inte att ge den billigaste.
På det sättet så väljer vi bort den som inte uppskattar det vi har.
Jag tror att det är viktigt att våga säga att det här är vi väldigt bra på.
Den som uppskattar det är vår kund.
Och verkligen bygga på det.
Och komma ihåg att leverera den produkten och den tjänsten riktat till den kunden, det är den starkaste bäraren av varumärket.
Det finns ju hur många exempel som helst.
Jag ska inte nämna dem i vår bransch, där man kan se där man har tagit starka varumärken och sen bara satt stickor på en ganska medioker utrustning.
Och då dör varumärkets magi in ganska så fort.
Så du måste verkligen se till att produkten, tjänsten som du levererar, den bär det varumärket och mot den du vill.
Det måste vara äkta i det för att du kan ljuga såklart under en period och du kan komma undan med det.
Men över tid så byggs, så måste din varumärkeshistoria, det måste rota sig i det du gör i den.
Sedan måste du vara återkommande konsistent i det du gör.
Repetition, repetition.
Det märker jag själv, att om man har chartat någon form av budskap länge så tycker man att nu får vi säga något annat, folk tycker vi är tråkiga.
Men då ska man fortsätta.
För att innan det där att satsa och våga vara konsistent i det, det är det.
För mig så är det verkligen den här ganska fundamentalistiska sakerna.
För vem vågar välja vårt, se till att det du levererar faktiskt är, bär det varumärket.
Du äkta, du orkar vara uthållig och driva det där det sitter.
Sedan kan man välja olika kanaler för att kommunicera sitt varumärke.
Man kan vara snäll och de kommer att skifta hela tiden.
Jag lyssnade på Noel Mack på Gymshark för ett tag sen, som har varit extremt duktiga på att etablera det varumärket.
Man har deras principkundprincipen, man sa att man ska se det som en chartersemester, där man ska vara tidigt ut och lägga handduken så man får den bästa platsen på stranden.
Han menade att det var med flera sociala medier, att de var först ut på Instagram, först ut på TikTok och så vidare.
Det kommer hela tiden att skifta.
Det är mycket svårare, ju mindre du är desto svårare kommer det vara att träffa rätt där hela tiden och hitta kanalen.
Men i grund och botten måste det komma tillbaka till att du genuin har kärnan på rätt plats.
Apropå det, leker Ileiko någonting med olika kanaler?
Det gör vi absolut, inte så mycket i HUSNU eftersom vi nu har gjort konsolideringen där vi har drabbat in det.
Men det gör vi absolut och testar i olika kanaler och var vi ska kommunicera var och definitivt.
Men jag skulle säga att där har vi ett utvecklingsområde för oss att bli bättre i den kanalstrategi än var vi varit.
Det har varit lite svårt nu för oss då vi har haft lokala kanaler överallt att hålla ihop det.
Men det är någonting som vi ser framför oss och att vi ska kunna bli bättre i det.
Tänker att den är lite knepig för er också.
Ni gjorde ju som du nämnde den här heavy-mug-reklamen som blev väldigt stor.
Jag fick reda på den genom att en vän till mig skickades mig, fan Joel, du borde ha gjort den här.
Kan du inte göra en större mug?
Vi hade ju kunnat göra det för vi är inte så seriösa.
Det passar våra nisch.
Men när ni gör den, absolut den får jättemycket spridning och det blir ju en rolig grej.
Men det är inte riktigt...
Den förstärker ju inte premiumnisch.
Det är ju lite knepigt när ni är just den nischen där ni är.
Är det någonting ni funderar på?
Jo men det gör vi ju och kanske mer och mer nu att just vad, hur kan vi jobba med det.
Samtidigt så ser vi ju för oss att det är viktigt att engagera och prata med vår community.
Och humor är en del som vi försöker få med oss i den för vi tycker ändå att det ska vara en del.
Vi får inte bli för stack-up.
Upplevas som för stack-up, för stela.
Vilket jag vet att man ibland kan tänka på oss på det sättet.
Så det är det men vi hade ju även en annan sån här socialmedia storm där vi lanserade vår app-mat.
Okej, den har jag inte sett.
Den kanske inte blev så stor.
Nej, vi lanserade ju en egen app-mat.
Och app-mat, det finns ju ett företag i USA som hade den första app-maten.
Men vi såg att vi vill ha en egen sådant.
Vi ser att vi på olika sätt kan göra den här bättre.
Det är ju ingen jätteprodukt för oss.
Och det finns hur många som helst som har gjort typ av app-mats runt om i industrin.
Jag tror att du kan hitta hundra olika sorter säkert.
Så vi gjorde det och sen lade vi...
Då gjorde vi en kort reklamfilm för den och bland annat stoppade vi den på vår social media.
De här appen gjorde fullständigt ramanskrig.
De kopierade vår reklamfilm.
Det tog ungefär ett dygn innan de hade gjort den och skickat ut den.
Det blev som ett community.
Eleko kopierar inte bara deras matta, de kopierar också deras reklamfilm, trodde folk i USA.
Lärdomen av det här var att vi måste vara ganska noggranna med hur vi använder vår kanalförspridning, som vi får idag, som är så stor.
Så vi måste tänka ett steg längre.
För grunden för oss var AdMat inte en jätteprodukt för oss.
Det var någonting vi tyckte att vi behövde, att vi skulle ha den, vi skulle göra den själv.
Vi valde om vi skulle sourcea eller göra den.
Men det var inte en jätteproduktlansering, alla en ny skivstång som gjordes.
Så där är lärdomar också för oss nu.
Vi måste ha en ganska bra linje i hur jag använder våra kanaler för att varumärket kan slå på andra hållet.
Att väldigt många tycker om oss.
Ja, jag förstår det blir ju ändå någonting som man håller ögonen på och som man kommer...
Jag är ju lite, lite hårdare i frågorna mot dig än vad jag varit mot de tidigare gästerna.
Just för att det känns nästan som att man får vara det.
För att det förväntas att man får vara det.
Det blir lite så och då tittar man ju på sociala medier.
Om ni producerar en Instagram-kanal som är okej, så kommer man typ att bli kritisk.
Medan om jag lägger upp en bild på mig själv när jag duschar, så tycker folk att det var väl okej.
Det kommer ju tillbaka med att du måste vara konsistent.
Har du lagt att det här är det som är leko, det här är den nivån som man förväntas av, så måste vi kontinuerligt leverera på den nivån hela tiden.
Det gäller nog alla, det är väl tvärtom om du normalt lägger upp dina duschbilder och helt plötsligt så har det kommit en jättepå.
Det kom en massa följare nu.
Så hade det väl gått omvänd, men det där är ju den stora utmaningen i det, att man också lära äntetat, för det är det många som tycker.
Jag vet att internt hos oss kan det bli väldigt jobbigt ibland när det blir för negativ feedback av olika anledningar att just hantera det på olika sätt.
Såklart, det är ju rimligt.
Det är ju en del som kommer med, presterar du på topp inom idrott eller presterar du på topp som artist eller vad som helst så kommer du få kritik.
Inte för att du är dålig utan för att du ställs mot en viss standard.
Så är det och sen får vi hela tiden utvärdera oss.
Vi gör ju saker som man kan i efterhand säga att det var kanske inte så jättebegåvigt.
Så får man utvärdera sig själv och så får man göra bättre nästa gång.
Så får man kanske vara utmjukt mot communityn.
Det här blev kanske inte som vi hade tänkt det.
Vi ber om ursäkt för det.
Men det är klart att ju mer proaktig man kan vara desto bättre är det ju.
Jag tycker det är grymt.
Jag tycker att vi har fått ihop ett fantastiskt uppsnitt.
Det var bra, för min första podd.
En grym succé.
Lever upp till Ico.
Tack, tack, tack.
Jättetack och tack för att du ville vara med.
Tack.
Det var kul att vara med, intressant samtalsämne och hoppas att vi skapat ett värde.
Det tror jag nog.
Medan som jag lägger upp en bild på mig själv när jag duschar, så tycker folk att det var väl okej.